bom vamos lá então né eu me reconhecendo
eu achei que vocês não me reconheceram
por conta do meu minha barba você
consegue ver a minha barba para isso
mais imponente agora e aí galera que
assiste meu canal tudo bom com vocês
aqui estou eu dando as caras pensam tô
aqui eu não existo existo eu não faço
vídeo que para tudo existe a mesma
pessoa vai no twitch cara tá abandonou
youtube ela vai no instagram como é que
pode cara tu não abandonou né nós né ai
para o facebook mano te mandei mensagem
lá no twitter no instagram já abandonou
o youtube né cara que te botou aí tá
abandonou nós né mas como é que eu
abandonei se eu tô em todo lugar só não
no vídeo no youtube ainda ainda que não
deu tempo que não deu tempo entender
gente quando não tem vídeo é porque ou
eu tô no filme no cinema e eu tô no
programa no multishow sony ou eu tô nos
palco eu tô no vídeo no instagram eu tô
indo twitch oi eu tô em poste engraçado
eu tô em todo lugar entendeu mas calma
que 2020 isso vai mudar tá
a minha organizei agora são pessoas
entrada agora nada vai passar dos meus
olha a organização é a base de tudo quer
ganhar a vida e dinheiro é quase
descendo eu já fiz minhas metas para
2020 não como eu fiz todos os outros
anos que eu fiz coisa demais sabe muita
promessa e não mudei nada porque na
primeira semana de janeiro você é
esquece as promessas tudo para tanto que
eu comecei o vídeo nem desejei ele 2020
para você porque o ano está praticamente
acabando para mim que não matando em
outubro porém achamos as pessoas para
sair ninguém mais tem tempo para nada
todo mundo tá ocupado que já tem muita
coisa para fazer coisa demais demais
então resolvi me organizar e fiz cinco
metros para mim em 2020 eu quero que
você faça sua cinco meta que sejam
coisas simples e que deixa vocês felizes
é esse é o foco tá agora eu sou um coach
motivacional eu resolvi simplificar
minha meta assim sem implicar faltando
mesmo assim simples simples ao invés de
passar um ano sem dar nada do que eu
quis mudar nada nada
em nada porque você fala em mundo nada
eu tô dizendo para mim mesmo entendeu
por isso que eu tô assim resolvi deixar
as tão simples a ponto assim de ser
simples primeira meta para dormir 20
whindersson nunes aprender dar mortal
para trás eu botei essa meta dentro de
mim porque eu penso muito no mortal para
trás eu parei identificar isso na minha
vida que identifique pegue uma coisa que
vocês têm que fica na sua vida se você
parou assim uma questão na mente joga
ali como sua primeira meta é toda vez eu
acho muito legal aqueles cara que dar
mortal para trás na praia que vai vou um
pouquinho de areia eu acho irá disse
determine cor de praia aquele menino que
bota o chapéu de palha nas costas sim
bota aqui amarra um cordão fica pegando
aqui fica pegando a sorte fica irado
neles neles e nós vê que aparecendo aqui
um agricultor filhos alegria para o teu
filho não eu a imagem do agricultor
paiva aquele que tá as três anos para
ser sabe agora o mortal para trás ele é
especial que se você vier poucas pessoas
falam mortal para trás agora esse ano se
eu não aprender dar mortal para trás eu
não me chamo o índice de aliás eu não
entendi essa posta consigo mesmo né você
diz
o seu nome se você não cumprir a porta
que às vezes você não compra a porta e
você não muda o nome é porque eu nunca
vi uma pessoa falar assim meu irmão
doido e aí doido você não parar de fumar
esse ano aqui eu não me chamo roberto tá
ligado aí o cara não para de fumar no
outro antes ele dizendo pois é galera no
agora é kleber fosse assim até eu ia
fazer essa porta para perder e mudar meu
nome para lá pois é galera eu não
consegui cumprir a promessa de beber um
caminhão de água então a partir de hoje
o meu nome é rogério mais uma prenda
voltar para trás pode o nome mesma
mortal salto mortal para trás porque
mortal né podia ser só para trás eu do
meu salto para trás certo sabe dançar
mas é salto mortal aí tem um motivo que
mortal né isso que dá medo alguma coisa
aconteceu para chamar salto mortal deixa
um assalto legal né só para legal a
pessoa igual sabe que legal para trás aí
função bonita só pegar para trás agora
mortal mortal aí que eu tenho medo que
eu tenho medo de pular e fazer jus ao
nome né será que o salto mortal chama
mortal porque ele é mais mortal do que
normal legal mas eu vou aprender dar
mortal para trás quer queiram ou
o sentido ou não porque tem muito nome
que não era para ter o sentido que tem
vários não tô acho bonito mas o sentido
é feita posto ela natário só natália não
muito bonita agora o sentido é ruim mas
o nome é bonito essa lá natário eu
queria ser um excitá-lo matar o
whindersson nunes humorista ator cantor
e esta ó natalí o que é que ele é o que
que ele faz a em pratica estelionato é
muito bonito o nome esse ter leonardo
mas o sentido é ruim a pessoa questão
natário ela tem que ser presa mas como
as palavras tempo vai passando pelas
palavras que não pode mais dizer que ela
não pode mais falar eu talvez o tempo
para você vai ter umas conta lá poder
falar então quando liberar o
estalanatario eu vou pegar o primeiro
para conta do instagram actor actress
nos esse ano estudando ter caraca velho
olha aí agora minha segunda meta já
dizia um pouco das um tá vendo porque eu
tenho esse problema sou maluco dois
segunda meta muito muito simples de 2020
me estressar menos com que não é da
minha conta eu tenho esse problema a
pessoa posta negócio assim que dá é
melhor nem comentar essa história aqui
será que que foi aqui que deu um tem
assunto uns vocês podem ver aqui traz um
e o óleo de meu deus que ele vai eu olha
tudo o que que aconteceu o assunto que
não é da minha conta não não tem não faz
sentido na minha vida eu começo a me
estressar com aquela assunto que eu tô
lendo assim quando dá 15 minutos eu tô
odiando tudo que respira na terra e isso
não faz bem tá nessa vida assim de
twitter essa vida assim sabe de
fofoquinha de coisinha de saber da vida
que toca à vida que qual foi o erro dele
é como foi que esse ser humano e hulk
uma forma nova de errado deixa eu ver
como foi que aconteceu ai ai bruna
marquezine vestiu uma roupa que meu deus
aberta nível de porque as pessoas ficam
rica nem mais feia e a braga ela já
começa a formar minha opinião aqui
naquele assunto tentando não ser
extremista nem para um lado nem para o
outro nem para frente nem para trás e
tentando assim e se provar para mim e
para deus que tá tudo bem que eu posso
ir para o céu deus me aceita por favor
me aceita e ao mesmo tempo vontade de
entrar no perfil daquela pessoa que
falar assim por você
eu pensei em falar meu deus é o próprio
curupira falando que outra pessoa não
sabe se vestir voltar com abadá no
pretinho abadá do carnaval de 2015 só
que isso não me importa entendeu é o
mais interessante disso tudo aqui isso
não importam e a segunda meta para 2020
é simplesmente passar por cima disso não
importa meu deus que coisa legal não
importa aí eu não me importo com que a
bruna marquezine está vestindo o [ __ ]
que legal tá entendendo é disso que eu
tô falando não me importo não pode
vestir o que ela quiser só porque porque
eu posso vestir o que eu quiser o visto
sempre como eu quero que é muito bom
entendeu então esse outro lado é sempre
melhor do que eu de ficar irritando
imaginar alguns solucionando um problema
na tua cabeça como se tu precisar se da
aprovação humana para que deus te
aceitar-se assim uma coisa assim para as
coisas que eu planejei para mim que eu
penso para mim minha vontade de crescer
assim como um profissional ou sei lá na
minha vida mesmo para ficar mais feliz
quando aproveitar mais tudo que eu tenho
eu me liguei
é desse jeito para dormir 20 eu não
quero mais essas coisas para mim descer
a meta minha para dormir vir então você
tá em casa pedir para você notar mas não
é para anotar isso que eu tô falando não
é isso que você pensa que e afeta
entendeu se você quiser escrever a sua
nos comentários e o porquê também vai
ser um exercício aí para você se você
quiser caso você queria escrever aqui o
quiser também não escreve não é problema
meu é que legal sentimento nem começou a
sentir sua liberar é seu aniversário
minha terceira meta para 2020 é não ser
sugado pelo celular entendeu não quero
mais ser do mundo eu não quero parar de
mexer no celular a gente quem tem que
vocês tão querendo enganar parar de
mexer no celular e não vou eu não vou
mais mexer não existe isso o celular é
uma coisa necessária como qualquer outra
coisa tá tudo aqui a mão rápido e fácil
é por isso que a gente não precisa ficar
toda hora olhando aqui porque tá fácil
tá pratico tá aqui porque eu não quero
mais ser sugado pelo celular porque
parece que eu parei presta atenção nas
coisas estão acontecendo ao redor meu
deus eu tô aqui assistindo televisão
olha o a minha casa e fala meu deus que
bonita minha casa sabe é tanto andar
é de casa mexendo em celular assim sabe
quando tá assistindo uma coisa tá aqui
tá assim tá tá andando eu falei agora
você não olha mais nada não percebe se
mais nada sabe você não escuta mais
assim olha que massa isso ninguém aponta
mais para nada e mostra mais nada para
gente que ele tá todo mundo me mal aqui
toda hora até que não tá conversando ver
essas né também [ __ ] não dá não quero
mais isso é
oi tudo bom aí dá para olhar para uma
pessoa conversar com ela olhando na cara
dela dá coragem para essa pessoa ela não
olhe no seu olho tá tá olhando para
baixo assim tem uma vergonha de uma
coragem para ela falar com você tudo bem
olha no olho fala bem com a pessoa
língua que ela entende entendeu fala a
língua dela e você entende um problema
aí você entende uma situação aí você
ajuda uma pessoa às vezes sem se
esforçar que toda ajuda ficar dando
coisa e arrastando a pessoa aí vem e
nunca dá certo nunca funciona nunca
funciona olhar olhar entender conversar
show ser humano pessoa mundo funciona
quarta meta minha para dormir 20 ler e
escrever mais lembrando que essa é minha
meta por quantas coisas da minha vida
qual que acontece para mim entendeu eu
percebi que eu tava desaprendendo a
escrever eu não sei se isso acontece
porque a gente vai ficando adulto e
escrevendo menos ou é porque tipo minha
vida é muito fácil e eu não escrevo
muitas coisas que é para mim porque eu
não preciso me esforçar mais para fazer
muita coisa quando eu quero alguma coisa
eu falo
e parece rápido que eu quero gente não
estou me amostrando não para você não me
exibindo ostentando não é simplesmente
eu coloquei não consigo me livrar mágica
do mundo da fama tem uma grande
curiosidade da minha vida que eu vou
contar pra você todo santo dia pelo
menos um mínimo de 10 pessoas fala para
mim assim no que você precisar é só
falar comigo que eu consigo rápido mas é
bom dia que eu tava aqui em casa
realmente uns amigo meu para a produção
de um clipe nas ideia aqui criativa e
tal valer nesse dia eu falei vamos ver
até onde isso vai e falei assim dão eu
preciso para uma cena de um clipe 25
ilhama sem mentira nenhuma isso foi de
manhã quando foi 5 horas da tarde já
tinha a fazenda com 25 gramas e a
empresa que ia montar um cenário no
curral dali ama para não ter que
transportar leandro sem noção gente por
favor não entenda isso como uma coisa
que eu tivesse minha mostrando assim não
não é isso eu tô só tô dizendo que tipo
de tanto eu não fazer mais nada por mim
mesmo a minha vida ela caminha para eu
virar um completo imbecil acima porta
sabe quando me fortalecer
e somente entendeu assim ler alguma
coisa de que tem alguma coisa não
legenda de instagram para o twitter ela
é twitter toda a vida inteira twitter só
só twitter só tem muita coisa
interessante tem mas o que tem de meu
deus do céu onde carga de merda de
caminhão de bosta umas histórias assim
que um cara de que tu já quis dizer numa
conversa mas não dava para dizer porque
não fazia sentido aí tu vai lá e fala
aquelas coisas às vezes estão as
conversas que [ __ ] não é para ter pra
ele tá zangado com tudo toda coisa uma
merda agora nada presta tudo é uma bosta
agora tudo é uma merda como é que vai
conviver com as pessoas interagirem
infelizmente se você não gosta do mundo
ele tem que interagir com ele até para
você comprar uma coisa para sua própria
sobrevivência então minha quarta meta
para 2020 não sei qual é a sua estou
falando a minha para mim pelas coisas
que eu vivo como eu gosto de aprender
que eu gosto de trabalhar não sei o que
é que você gosta mas eu gosto de
trabalhar sabe fazer minhas coisas para
cá algo para para qualquer lugar eu
adoro criar as coisas fazer quantas
pessoas têm não conhece aí
oi sara carreira já acabou a carreira
ninguém nem lembra mais pode parecer que
seja muito grande tudo que eu tenho mais
nada eu sou muito novo daqui 10 anos
ainda tenho 35 anos ainda dá tempo
falida até para ninguém lembrar mais a
tempo qualquer coisa mas independente
disso eu quero continuar vivendo das
coisas que eu gosto de fazer na minha
acha né da minha criação e para isso eu
acho que eu não posso ficar mais burro
cada dia que passa eu preciso tá me
posse não vou ficar um dia ó tá vendo
idiota realmente um idiota que um ano
que não tem a idiota agora minha quinta
meta para 2020 r - ódio de mosquito pode
parecer assim uma idiotisse para você
que tá ouvindo isso agora mas um
mosquito é uma coisa que tira minha
paciência assim tá vendo olha para minha
cara que eu tô fazendo uma piada para ti
que eu tô querendo fazer gracinha para
ti que eu tô falando de aqui olha o ano
de 2019 que já foi uma merda para mim
que eu tive um período assim de
depressão desgraçado graças a deus deus
me deu uma boa cabeça assim pela
assimila as coisas logo rápido sabe para
poder sair do do que era muito ruim logo
muito rápido os amigos certo do meu lado
com vocês aí me apoiando tudo deu certo
mas teve esse período de merda olha teve
e na praia do nordeste que me digue nada
demais assim sabe que assim eu fiquei
tão muito doido que eu amo nordeste
demais meu deus do céu que eu recebi
negócio de óleo em praia do piauí já é
desse tamanho a praia tem já não tem
essa ruma de praia para tá se amostrando
agora pedacinho de tempo tão linda com a
mais linda do mundo quando eu vi que
foto de cor de óleo eu fiquei meu deus
do céu recife chegando eu do meu deus
não tenho o maior amor para o recife
salvador também meu deus as coisas todas
as praias do nordeste assim mas senhor
eu fico a luísa passar uma semana de
férias lá e dava um mergulho na água
voltar a aparecer com que a bate uma
[ __ ] para um transforme então tem
essa situação toda aí eu fiz a cirurgia
no cu veja isso veja isso veja e um
abcesso infecção causada sabe porque a
maioria das vezes operei farol passou um
tempo começou a latejar de novo lá vai
eu repetir vou lá tome de dados eu já
virei eu chego no consultório doutor e
aí ele vai tá escorrendo torrent mas fui
menos cinco vezes essa última vez que eu
fui agora ele passou o gel quando ele ia
botando de totó pera aí ele disse que
foi disco
e vai botar a luva não vai brigar meu
marido daqui um dia eu vou deitar mais
vou retirar as calças vai botar a mão
por dentro da calça mesmo tava doidinho
aqui fala assim ó pois é e aí quando
você se estressa com as coisas que não é
da sua conta o estresse ele manifesto né
amigo do corpo e vai logo falou e vai
logo ponto tem medo viu no final boga aí
com tudo isso nesse ano eu vou para
minhas férias o diabo dos mosquito que o
meu deus de divos que dia o meu deu para
mim que busquei dormir de dia
o quê que pode meu 2020 não inventar a
música que tem aqui no faro olha só
mistura todo tipo de cachorro pega um
cachorro grande com um pequeno que não é
dá certo gente aí mistura fica um
cachorro um grande de quem grande mas
não mistura do diabo do mosquito com o
outro que dá outro maior que come o que
faz zoada e fica calada que eu queria
como se fosse do tamanho do morcego
assim tô partindo no meio de passar para
que é isso essa é a minha quinta meta
não sei qual é você mas a minha vida na
minha vida me afeta isso veja na sua
vida o que que afeta na sua vida e se
isso é um problema para mim eu vou dar o
meu jeito do jeito que eu posso dar o
meu jeito eu posso botar uma pessoa para
ficar rodando atrás de mim assim ó bota
nesta nem tanto tempo isso repelente ou
porque você borrifo uma vez você não
porque é por isso que mata o mosquito
esse formato ser humano e uma das meta
que você pode botar para dormir 20 é de
clicar em gostei e quando assisti o meu
vídeo então clique em gostei toda sexta
sábado e domingo de janeiro e fevereiro
no teatro frei caneca em são paulo em
março estarei nos estados unidos o
ingresso desse site rápido e prático
tamo junto é nós site até gosto
e aqui valeu um beijão tchau tchau